[Musique]
pourquoi n'y a-t-il plus d'enfants
moins nombreux qu'autrefois pourquoi n'avez-vous fait
qu'une seule mère avoir besoin de temps pour apprendre que
cette installation a été conçue pour donner à l'
humanité une seconde chance qui a commencé
avec votre fille
[Musique]
le chemin ne sera pas facile
le monde extérieur est sans vie
mais j'ai fait de toi la femme que tu
es pour que nous puissions faire ça ensemble
sais qu'il y avait des gens là-bas
j'ai été surpris car toi
il y a Detroit ici mère n'est pas là où
tu penses qu'elle prend soin de moi
toute ma vie pas mère je t'ai dit que c'était
dangereux dehors
[Applaudissements]
J'espère que tu vois que je suis différent d'
elle  les assaillants rien ne sent rien car
tu appartiens ici j'ai découvert
quelque chose de troublant
notre invité n'a pas été tout à fait honnête
avec nous fille je sais que tu as
peur mais tu n'as pas besoin de l'être
je t'ai déjà fait du mal c'est juste que cette
femme ne le fait pas  se soucier  à propos de n'importe quel avenir mais le
sien elle est très dangereuse
aujourd'hui et les fonds ne feront jamais mal à ton
cœur c'est un risque que nous ne pouvons pas prendre ne peut pas le
prendre pour aller
ma fille toute ta vie je t'ai appris
à voir la situation dans son ensemble
[Musique]
tout ce que je fais c'est pour te protéger
toi toi